COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER.
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT AN AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING IS BEING
MADE OF TODAY'S PROCEEDING.
AND IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED
KATERI PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HERE.
CERVANTES HERE GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON HERE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE.
MAGUS PRESIDENT NAZARIAN THE
PRESIDENT TOLERANCE PRESIDENT
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE ALSO
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA IS THAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION MOVED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES SECONDED
BY.
SO REMEMBER SALAS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CARILLO.
CARILLO I CERVANTES CHAU
CERVANTES AYE AND GALLAGHER
GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE YEAH KAMLAGER-DOVE
AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE NAZARIAN
BY.
THOSE THERE AND I SALAS SITE.
WALDRON.
MODERNIZE MUCH BECAUSE THIS
MOTION IS PASSED THE RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
RIGHT